let's go enough of this crap in five  this Black Friday some of your favorite  products will be marked down 20 30 maybe  even 40% or more but what if you don't  feel like buying more crap but do feel  like getting in on the Black Friday  melee right well then come on down to  trample warehouse where we got pushes we  got shoves all of that all right  but no products none of the Merchants  Bank you don't sleep seriously don't  throw a goddamn thing I didn't get any  deals but I did drop a [ __ ]  we've got one door and we've got wet  floors without all the products getting  the way there's more room for booze and  flash this is all normal if you can't  stand you manatee have unchecked  aggression issues yet deeply desire to  rub up against your fellow humans they  come on down to trample warehouse  located at no.4 alchemy drive in  Bridgeview bring a helmet  you